it's very very scary too to be judged by
the color of your skin it's happened to
me quite a bit my my whole life you know
what I mean even even how people
describe me on Scrubs
I'm the black guy from scrubs you know
what I mean I'm not even one of the
actors from scrubs I'm the black guy
from scrubs and so I encourage everyone
to just first of all educate yourself
that's wow most important you know what
I mean once you educate yourself you'll
you'll be able to see that you know
everyone pretty much is the same we
might do things differently but we all
are the same and together we can abolish
racism and it's everywhere and once you
also once you recognize that once you
recognize racism is everywhere it's it
never left it's always been here you
know what I mean it's not a surprise
that this is going on right now it's
it's finally coming to a head is what's
happening it's been here forever and
once you start once you don't take that
for granted and you recognize that
there's racism out there you'll start
checking yourself you'll start checking
yourself believe it or not subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going